in the last video we thought about how
we would allocate our five dollars
between chocolate bars and fruit and the
way we did it was very rational we
thought about how much bang would we get
for each buck and we saw look starting
off our first dollar we had a lot of
bang for our buck and this is really
just another way of saying bang for the
buck marginal utility per price so we
got a lot of utility propriety starting
off for that first chocolate bar a
little less for that next chocolate bar
but still more than we would get per for
a pound of fruit then we get it we then
more for the next chocolate bar and only
then and only then did we start buying
some fruit buying some pounds of fruit
what I want to do in this video is
generalize it I want to think about
maybe a more continuous case where we
can buy very very very small increments
of each of the products it doesn't have
to be in chunks like chocolate bars and
then and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to going to plot the marginal
utility per price which is really bang
for your buck on the vertical axis so
this right over here on this axis let's
say this is the marginal utility per
price and let's say it also goes from 0
to 100 so that would be 50 and the
numbers actually don't matter so much
here and then this will be dollar spent
so dollars dollars spent so your buck so
this is bang for your buck and that this
is your buck so this is one two three
four five and six now we're going to to
arbitrary products so let's say one
product looks something like this and
then once again you have diminishing
utility as you get more and more of that
product in the case of through the more
pounds of fruit you get the more tired
you get a fruit the less you the less
fruit you need for that or or the less
you want fruit for that next incremental
pound
so let's but it does it could be
anything this is true of most things so
this is product a it could be a service
as well so product a let me write it
this way so this is the marginal utility
for a / price / price of a and let me
get another product right over here so
let's say my other product looks
something like this so this is this is
my marginal utility for product B
the per price of B so it's really saying
bang for the buck so just to start off
just to start off and I won't even
I won't even constrain how much money we
have I just want to think about how we
would spend that money so if I were to
spend if I had a penny where would I
spend that penny and I'm assuming I can
buy these in super small chunks the
smallest maybe the the penny or even
maybe fractions of penny so if I just
had a penny and I think about where am I
getting the best bang for my buck for
that penny I'm clearly getting it with
product a so I would spend that penny on
product day and I would get this much
bang for my buck which would which would
be this entire part which would be this
entire part right over here let me color
it in
so my first I'll spend it right on a let
me do it a color that's more likely to
be seen so I'll do it in this blue color
so I'll spend it on a my first in fact
where would I spend my first dollar well
the whole first dollar I'm getting a
better bang for my buck on a so my first
dollar I will spend on a and the total
utility I will get is actually going to
be the area under this curve it's going
to be this whole area it's going to be
dollars times marginal utility price
that would give you obviously the area
of this rectangle right over here the
reason why it wouldn't be the area of
this larger rectangle it would just be
the area under the curve is you're not
getting you're not getting this a
hundred marginal utility per price for
the entire dollar it's going down the
entire time and so that your actual
total marginal utility is actually just
the area under this and if you when you
take calculus you'll get better
appreciation for that but let's just
think about once again where our dollar
is going to be spent so our actually
even our after even we spent already $1
our next penny we'd still want to spend
on product a because we're still getting
more bang for the buck we're still
getting more bang for the buck all the
way until right around there now
something interesting is happening so
we've spent about $2 we spent our first
two dollars all on product a because
we're getting more bang for our buck
even though that bang was diminishing
every penny or even every fraction of a
penny that we spent but now where will
we spend our next our next penny well we
could spend it on product a again but
look we can get about the same marginal
utility spending it on
be so we could jump right over there
spend it on product B now where could we
spend our next dollar well we get about
the same marginal utility whether we
spend it on a little bit more product B
or a little bit more product a so we
could do either if we spent a little bit
too much on product a then we could have
gotten more marginal utility spending on
product B so what we would do is once
we've gotten to this threshold right
about right about here we actually are
going to spend every incremental
fraction of a penny we're actually going
to want to split between product a and
product B if we spend too much on one
and we go down this curve we could have
gotten higher utility spending on on on
this one if we spent too much on this
one we could get higher utility spending
on this one right over here so there's a
very interesting phenomenon here
assuming that we eventually spend enough
that we buy some of both obviously we
started just buying product a because it
had higher utility at least for those
first few dollars but assuming that we
end up buying some mix of the two which
we do end up spending if we spend more
than two dollars there's an interesting
thing the marginal utility for project
the marginal utility for for B or the
marginal utility for price for B that I
spend on that last little increment is
going to be the same as a marginal
utility per price for that last
increment of a so if this was if B was I
don't know if it was fruit and let's say
a was chocolate but we can buy him in
very very small increments we're saying
for that last fraction of a pound of of
fruit you're spending thus it you're
getting the same marginal utility per
price as you're getting for that last
fraction of a bar or fraction of a pound
of chocolate so there's a general
principle over here and it really just
comes from this very straightforward
thing that as soon as you can get better
marginal utility on the other one you
start spending there but then they start
to look equal and you would keep
dividing your money between the two and
so the general principle if you're
allocating money between two goods for
that last increment not across the board
just that last increment that's why the
word marginal is so important for that
last ounce of chocolate versus that very
last ounce of fruit the marginal the
marginal utility per price for that last
increment of one good will be the same
as the marginal
the marginal utility per price of the
second good now I really want to
emphasize what this is saying this is
not saying that the marginal utilities
for price of the two goods are the same
and not even that their one is better
than the other this is just saying as
you spend money let's say you spend
enough money to buy both at some point
you're going to get to a threshold where
you're neutral between the two where the
marginal utility per price is the same
at for eat for an incremental of B
versus an incremental of a and at that
point you're just going to keep
switching you're just going to keep
switching between the two products
because obviously if you focus too much
on this right over here let's say you
focus let's say at that point you switch
and you just start buying a bunch of you
just start buying a bunch of product B
right over here well that didn't make
sense because you were buying product B
when you could have actually gotten
higher marginal utility buying some of
product a and that's the same reason why
you didn't just keep going down a
because you could have gotten higher
marginal utility over here this is
closer to I don't know 75 while you're
only getting seventy right over here